so thank you very much everybody for
being here it's a tremendous pleasure
myself to be here I am going to talk
about a book that I'm writing with
Robert Shiller called fishing for fools
so this is meant to be a popular book
their rules as an economist you're not
supposed to write popular books you're
supposed to so the rules of what can and
cannot be published in economics and
those rules leave holes there are valid
and important things to say but there's
no way to save them that's acceptable in
any journal for example quite a few
economists thought the derivatives would
lead to the current crisis but
economists could not figure out a way to
express those views in the form of a
paper now because of the because of the
rules for what could be published those
papers were not written and so it was
ignored and because it was ignored we
had the financial crisis and of course
the financial crisis is the central
event in the history of our tongs so
with that preface let me begin the
world's most powerful social and
economic tool is the free global market
it enables the world's adults to trade
with one another worldwide there's some
25g quillian possible pairs of buyers
and sellers and you can as you can see
up there a [ __ ] Willian or even 25g
quillian is really quite a big number I
can't count the number of zeros from
here the selection that this huge amount
of choice of Ford's to both buyers and
sellers makes us all better off but then
yet more important our new ideas
billions of new ideas are natural he
adopted by free markets year after year
and they make us better off because of
this technical change our older retirees
in both in Canada and the US we're born
in countries that were poor than bet
present-day in Mexico now markets are
capable of such power for good because
they allow so much positive selection
but not all so here's where fishing for
fools comes in so the markets are
wonderful that's the first message but
not all of those ideas are good for you
and good for me some of those ideas are
good for you but they're bad for me and
associated with such ideas come the
tricks the tricks to inveigle me into a
buying in so markets then do the
following they aim for our weak spots
they seek out and take aim for our
emotional and/or cognitive weaknesses
they seek to block our channels of
information and then take advantage of
those weaknesses so what does this mean
markets do not just enable such fishing
for fools markets inevitably they
inevitably do so as long as there's a
profit to be made so is that that's the
basic principle of economics if there's
a profit to be made on something then
that's going to happen and so the story
here is the fishing for fools is
inevitable and this in fact is armed
what happens so what is fishing fish is
a recent word its computer ease now free
markets open us up to those who seek to
influence us to do what they want but
that's not necessarily good for
ourselves they allow us in other words
to be fished so as I said before we live
in a world where some five billion
adults can fish us for being a fool so
we've intentionally opened us up selves
up to such exploitation we've done so
because of the obvious advantages but
then we must also think about the other
side of that bargain so I'm going to
give you three examples I'm going to
give you three examples which show that
fishing for fools is deeply embedded
it's deeply embedded in our economy and
then furthermore it plays a major role
in our law
so health so here's an example in the
United States three quarters of all
adults are overweight yet worse a third
are not just overweight but Abby's so
free markets they help us with this a
little bit they give us Weight Watchers
they give us vegetables we can bought
tomatoes i think and Diet Coke and Pepsi
and those are some help to those of us
who are concerned about our weight but
if you go to almost any mall any place
in the country there will be the smell
of those sinha bonds and those sinha
bonds are going to be waiting for you I
think maybe I've got a picture of a
Cinnabon here yes there's a cinnamon
okay that smell like a monster amount is
a call to all of us overweight obese
people so just to give you some
statistics between 1970 and 2003 the
u.s. day leave kept food calorie intake
increased by 20 three-point-four percent
480 of those 523 calories increase were
in fats and oils and grains and sugars
now Cinnabon here Cinnabon is a metaphor
it's a metaphor for them tations that
the market screws in our path okay so
that's one example of fishing for fools
okay so now that takes us to the next
example people for the most part seem to
have a hard time saving okay and this is
Suze Orman you probably are familiar
with Suze Orman who gives financial
advice on TV and if you're not familiar
you can get the picture um so what I
asked an economist friend of mine about
her he had the predictable reaction he
had he said he could not stand her mommy
knows best voice and he had seen her for
only 10 seconds and had switched her aww
but that doesn't explain a puzzle that
does not explain why Orman's audiences
laugh her up so our most popular book
has the following title it's called the
nine steps to financial freedom
practical steps so you can stop worrying
and I underlined worrying there so let's
contrast what she said tells us there
with the portrait given if consumer
spending in the economics textbooks well
onion if you've read the economics
textbooks we go to the supermarket and
we have a budget we have budget for how
much we're going to spend on those
apples and oranges now with that budget
we purchase the combination of apples
and oranges that maximizes or happiness
but Suze Orman's financial advice books
tell us the consumers do not follow such
a textbook protocol in their purchases
so how could consumers do anything other
than that than what the textbooks aside
I'm an economist actually I think of
probably do what's what it do this thing
this rational thing but buts Orman's
people don't she tells us that people
have emotional hang-ups with regard to
money and with regard to spinning it he
says they're not honest themselves and
as a consequence they do not engage in
rational budgeting so how could she
possibly know well she has a test she's
a financial advisor when she asked her
financial advisers to add up their
expenditures those expenditures
invariably fall far short of what
documented records later turn up
figuratively relative to the proverbial
trip to the supermarket to buy apples
and oranges it's as if ur advisees spend
too much time in the fruit section and
by the time they reach dairy products
there's nothing left over for the eggs
and the milk in real life such budgetary
failure translates into having nothing
left over for savings this failure to
deal cognitively and emotionally with
money says Orman leads to those unpaid
bills so it's her mission it's her
mission she's a good person to keep
those built to keep those bills down so
the term readers and her clients will no
longer worry at night and it's worth
noting parenthetically at least that
worries are central concerns of
financial advice books but they're far
into economics
sports I've never found the word worry
in the index to an economics book so um
I can you just give you two examples of
the fact that this applies to most
consumers for British workers who were
paid once a month expenditures are down
twenty percent on average by the day
before their next paycheck for the
United in the united states
approximately twenty to twenty-five
percent of all US residents would go
bankrupt over the course of their
lifetime so there's a theoretical puzzle
why are there all those sleepless nights
with worries about unpaid bills well
back in nineteen thirty john maynard
keynes wrote an essay an essay on what
life would be like for our grandchildren
what's presumably a hundred years later
he predicted correctly that by now
income would be would have increased
some six times and he was correct on
that but another respect he was way off
the mark he said that we would all be
feeling so rich that the workweek would
fall to 15 hours we would spend most of
our time and leisure but our book
coupled with Suze Orman explains why
Keynes predictions were wrong so here's
the answer to the puzzle the goal of
almost every business person is to get
you to spend your money life is a
proverbial trip to a parking lot in
which you're constantly passing spaces
left open for the disabled life and a
capitalist economy is then a continual
temptation so just think about it just
walk down any City Street those shop
windows are literally there to make you
come in and buy that is the purpose of a
shop window so you probably all know
this song about how much is the doggie
in the window so after they're probably
everybody listen so so that doggie that
doggie is sitting in the window and it's
supposed to entice you to come in and
buy and so that's what this is all about
you know what the girls we
don't have that song people probably
know the first verses up you probably
don't know happens in the second verse
the girl is walking down the street she
sees the nice doggie in the window and
she says she's going to go in and buy
now is he couldn't buy that doggie but
she's going to do something utterly
outrageous she's not gonna buy it for
herself she's going to take it home for
her boyfriend which might be perfectly
fine but she's going to leave for
California so that's what happens there
so that's what those shop windows do in
the shopping mall in the supermarket
everywhere temptation is they're asking
you to buy these invitations these
attempts to lure us there simply
pervasive and so most of us in this
richest of all ages go to bed at night
worried about paying the bills okay so
that's a second example of fishing for
fools the financial crisis okay well
they're hundreds of books on the
financial crisis and the typical book is
500 pages long and a lot there's been a
great deal of wonderful reporting on
this typical book then tells the story
of my institution for example people
write about layman or Goldman Sachs or
Fannie Mae Freddie Mac or the Fed the
Treasury the bank of america city court
etc and then the this nice reporter
who's gone at all the details says that
my institution is central to the crisis
but I'm going to tell this in less than
three minutes and in the book it's 12
pages ok so if I have a reputation if I
have a reputation for selling perfect
beautiful avocados then I have an
opportunity I can sell you a rotten
avocado at the price you would pay for
the perfect ripe one what will I have
done I will have mind my reputation but
not only oh I mind my reputation but
I've also will have fished you for a
fool so it's just a story lies at the
heart of the continuing financial crisis
that dominates the economics of our time
the reputation of mining in question
involved the subversion of the system
for raiding fixed income securities the
reputations of Moody's and Standard in
pores had been built up painstakingly
over the course of almost a century
their job was to rate bonds on their
probability for default but then as you
all know in the late 1990s and early
nine two thousand the ratings agencies
took on themselves the tasks not just of
rating bonds but also of raiding more
complex derivative securities the
complex eclectic laxity of the payment
structures made them nearly impossible
to rate but then the public would
believe whatever ratings were given to
them by the agencies and so an industry
grew up an industry grew up to do a
reputation mine so those are those
wonderful avocados that we're being
rated okay so by analogy by analogy
rotten avocados were being labeled
perfect with that label they can't they
commanded premium prices and so a
central valley full of growers a central
valley full of growers went into the
profitable business of producing such
avocados so this mining of the ratings
is the basic story of the financial
crisis now that's not all of the
explanation and I'm going to just give
you what's the rest of it just very
briefly collapsing financial
institutions bought these securities and
then they borrowed on them for the
moment of securities seemed as good as
gold and because the red ratings
indicate there was almost no chance of
default but then as you can imagine the
truth was discovered those avocados
perfect as they were on the outside were
really rotten they were really rotten on
the inside so from Frankfort to New York
to Reykjavik financial institutions owed
much more the
they owned and without bail out they
were bankrupt okay so I just giving you
a a few a handful of the many many many
examples that we're going to have in
this book fishing for fools now what's
the purpose of this book the purpose of
this book is to give an economics and
economics which is in a different key
it's not a major key it's a minor key
the two greatest economic mistakes of
the past 20 years the European monetary
union and deregulation of financial
derivatives occurred because economists
were not sufficiently skeptical we were
not sufficiently acceptable of what
happened in markets we were not
sufficiently skeptical of our own logic
so what the book is meant to do in
general is to teach us to be
appropriately skeptical but the same
time remember i started with tailing you
about how markets were really wonderful
and they really give us all the lots of
the things good things that we have but
so at the same time it also gives an
appropriate vision of how the good is
mixed with the bad so the purpose of the
book is to teach us to be skeptical but
it not to be cynical thank you very much
you